e
un héritage qui dépasse
largement le monde du sport,
- Just... the light
at the end of the tunnel!
(rires)
du tunnel", c'est ce que
Sere W Williams a déclaré
quand on lui a demandé ce qui
la
sa victoire, lundi, à Toronto.
CeCette lumière, c'est la liberé
que Serena espère trouver
professionnelle, amorcée
en 199àà Québec, où elle a joué
son premier tournoi, à 14 ans.
73 championnats en simple,elele.
Serena Williams est,selon plusi,
la plus grande championne
de l'histoire du tennis.gagagagr
olympique en simple à Londres
et en double avec sa soeur Venus
à Sydney, Pékin et Londres.
Les deux soeurininininininininis
des finales du grand chelem;
elles en ont gagné 14 ensemble.
Mais les soeurs Williams
ont la
ailleurs que sur le terrain.
(huées)ncncncncncncncncncncncncé
le racisme dont elles étaient
la cible. Et un incident
survenu en 2001 à Indian Wells,
où Serena et son pèmemememememet
amenées à boycotter le tournoi
pendant une dizaine d'années.
Serena n'a pas hésité non plus
de mère et d'athlète.
Dans le texte du Vogue,
elle souligne que si elle avait
continuer à jouer et gagner
des championnats aussi
longtemps que Tom Brady,
comme femme, puisqu'elle s'est
arrêtée pour donner naissance
à sa fille Olympia, en 2017.
Serena Williams a aussi eu
une in
du circuit de tennis
ofofessionnel féminin.
Bianca Andreescu a eu
deux fois à l'été 2019, quand
la Canadienne s'est imposée
sur la scène internationale
et au US Open, toutes deux
en finale contre Serena.
Des moments émouvants.
Serena Williams n'est venue
les Internationaux du Canada
et elle n'a jamais gagné ici,
s'inclinant en finale contre
Martina Hingis en 2001
et contre sa soeur Ven e e e e .
- Premièrement, je voudrais
dire merci à mmmère...
- Elle a quand même trouvé
le moyen de gagner
des partisane e e e e e e e e e.
VALÉRIE TÉTREAULT, Tennis Canada
- Et avant d'avoir j
de tennis, bien, elle est
Serena Williams  e elle est
allée bien au-delà du tennis
et même du monde du sport.
- Serena Williams pourrait
ac
le mois prochain. Elle tentera
alors de mettre la main sur
un 24e titre du grand chelem
sur le terrain où elle avait
Ici Jean St-Onge,
Radio-Canada, Montr